One of the biggest advantages to
building AI agents over traditional
workflows or automations is they're
supposed to act more like a human. That
intelligence to make decisions on the
fly and do things on your behalf is why
AI agents are oftenimes considered the
most important use case for LLMs. But
for being so humanlike, they sure have a
terrible memory most of the time. And I
have a very clean and simple solution
for this that I want to bring to you
today. Because here's the thing. Right
now, everyone is very focused on using
their documents to teach AI agents
through RAG. And that is certainly
important, but it isn't really memory.
What about giving our AI agents the
ability to not just learn through
documents we give it, but also through
our conversations? We want AI agents
that learn as we interact with them, so
they can remember things like our goals,
our preferences, instructions, or
corrections that we give our agent, and
the list goes on. this kind of long-term
memories when you really start to take
your AI agents to that next level of
personalization and humanlike behavior.
And in this video, I'll show you step by
step how to build one of these
self-learning agents using an open-
source Python library called Mem Zero,
which is simple to use and built for
exactly what we're trying to do,
building up knowledge, aka memories,
about individual users as they interact
with the agent. This tool is my best
friend right now. And if you stick till
the end of this video, I think it'll be
yours as well. So, let's dive into Mem
Zero right now, and then I'll show you
how easy it is to use to evolve your AI
agents. So, first of all, what does
long-term memory and Mem Zero solve for
us? So, I'm going to show you really
quick what a chat with an LLM looks like
that doesn't have this implemented, and
then I'll show you the end result, what
we're building towards right now, what
we can do with agents that have
long-term memory. And so as our first
test, I'm here chatting with Gemini 2.0
Flash. This is an agent or really just a
chatbot that doesn't have long-term
memory. And so for my first prompt here,
I'm just describing to it a text stack
that I'm using to build my SAS company.
And so now, theoretically, the chatbot
understands the different services that
I'm using for things like Reddus and
Superbase. But now, watch this. I'm
going to go into a new chat. And then in
this new chat, I'll ask it a question
around these services that I described
to it. So I'll say something like what
considerations should I have for my
database? And you would hope that if
this was really an intelligent agent, it
would remember my text stack between
conversations. But as you can see here,
there is nothing that it's giving me
that shows that it really understands
what I'm using. It references some
things like Reddus that I'm using, but
also it's just listing out a bunch of
different services like MongoDB, Oracle,
things that I did not mention in my text
stack at all. And so you can see that
Gemini doesn't have that long-term
memory. And so when I start a new
conversation with it, I have to fill it
in on all of the important details from
a previous conversation to get it up to
speed. And that is super annoying. So
now let's contrast this with an agent
that has long-term memory built with
mem. And so the final result, what we're
working towards in this video, I have
available for you to try for free right
now. So if you go to
studio.automator.ai, you'll see the
Pyantic AI mem agent. This is what we're
going to be building, but I want to show
you how this contrasts with Gemini. And
so I'll paste in the same prompt here
saying that I'm working on a SAS
company. Here is my tech stack. And so
we'll see just like before it
acknowledges my technologies. But then
when I go into a new conversation, and
I'll do that in a little bit here, it's
just processing the memories right now.
I'll go into a new conversation, ask
Gemini the same question, and this time
it'll be able to recount the technology
that I'm using. Give me something that
is a lot more tailored to me personally.
So, brand new conversation here. I'll
say, "What considerations should I have
for my database?" And so, I'll give it a
second to give me a response. Come back
and you'll see that the answer is going
to be much, much better. Boom. And there
we go. Take a look at this. when
considering the database for your SAS
company. So first of all it remembers
that I'm building a SAS company. Now
it's talking about Superbase Postgress
and if I do a search for Reddus here,
yep, it's talking about Reddus, my fast
API. Unlike Gemini, it's not referencing
technologies that I'm not using. It's
only referencing the things that I am
using. And this is a very basic example,
but I hope you can use your imagination
to just run wild with what your AI
agents are able to do when they can
remember past interactions with users
and start to almost build a user
specific knowledge base. And that's what
Mem does as well because it segregates
the memories by user using a user ID.
I'll show you how to use that with
superbase authentication later as well.
And getting started with Mem Zero could
not be easier. They have this GitHub
repo which I'll link in the description
of this video and you just have to pip
install Memzero AI once you have Python
on your machine. It is that easy. And
they have a platform to host Mem Zero
for you. Otherwise, if you want, you can
self-host this completely for free. It
is a 100% open- source project. That's
what we're going to be leveraging in
this video. I'll start with a very basic
implementation of Memzero, actually
based on this template that they have
right here. And then I'll get a little
bit more complicated over time to add in
really important things like superbase
authentication for our user
identification and also for our vector
storage for our memories. So most of the
time I find that to learn a new
framework or tool it makes sense to just
start building with it. And so that's
what we're going to do right here with
Mem Zero is dive right into the code. I
do have a section at the end of this
video covering a bit more how mem works
behind the scenes. So check that out if
you're interested. Stay till the end for
that. But right now, I just want to code
some things with you. So, this GitHub
repo that you're looking at right here,
I'll have a link in the description to
this. You can download this, follow the
read me for getting everything set up.
You can run all of this code that we're
going to be creating together. Also,
what we're going to be doing here is
going through iterations, starting
really basic with me zero. We're going
to code this from scratch together and
then going in steps to do things like
integrate Superbase for storing our
memories and then also building a simple
front end with superbase authentication
so we can have users log in to grab that
user ID for each user to store their
memories separately in a database. I
mean that's one of the biggest use cases
with Memzero. So I'll show you how to do
that. And then the last thing I'll say
here is that the repo also showcases the
studio integration version that I showed
earlier on the live agent studio. So, if
you're curious how to use Memzero to
build AI agents with Pyantic AI, check
out this code right here. It's a great
example for that. And so, with that,
let's dive into building a simple
implementation with Mezero. So, I'll be
sure to go step by step through
everything here to make sure it all
clicks for you. So, the first thing
we're going to be doing is importing our
libraries and our environment variables.
That's everything that we have set right
here, starting with just our OpenAI API
key for version one. But then for future
versions, we'll get into defining our
model through environment variables and
the configuration for superbase. And so
with that, we'll move on to setting up
our configuration for me zero. There is
a lot of different things you can define
here. And you can check the docs for
this like our database for example that
we'll see later. But right here, we're
keeping it very simple. Setting up the
configuration for our LLM. So when the
LLM is used by mem to extract memories
from the messages or perform a search we
are going to be using GPT4 mini just
keeping it very simple then we'll create
our openi client and our mem zero client
as well using this configuration as you
can see like we're doing right here and
then for our primary function for this
initial version we have chat with
memories so it takes two parameters we
have the current message from the user
and then we have the user ID ID because
we have to find a way to segregate the
memories between users and the user ID
is the way to do that. So we would never
want to accidentally fetch a memory from
a different user when someone is
chatting with our agent. So first we
retrieve the relevant memories. So using
the mem zero client we're just using the
search function passing in the latest
message from the user their ID and then
we are limiting to three three of the
most relevant memories and then we
create a string version of this just
referencing the object that's returned
right here. We want it to be a string
because we're passing that into the
system prompt. So it's just a very basic
system prompt that I have set up. You
are a helpful AI. Answer the questions
based on the user's latest message and
the memories that we are giving. right
here dynamically from what we retrieved
with mem zero. And then we create that
message array that we're going to pass
into the OpenAI client because this is
where we make our request to GPT4 Mini
with all of the messages that we
currently have built up in the
conversation. And this isn't a
conversational bot. You'll see here that
the messages that we pass in to GPT4
Mini, we only have the system prompt and
the user message, the latest user
message. We're not building up
conversation history over time. And this
is important because I'll show you in a
bit. We're going to prove that we don't
have any conversation history at all,
but the agent is still able to remember
things. And so, just keep that in mind.
We're not building up conversation
history. So we'll get the response from
the agent and then we will append to the
messages the response because we're
going to now take the user message along
with the AI response and we're going to
call the add function of the mem zero
client. So it's going to based on the
user message and AI response extract key
memories for our specific user and then
store that and right now it's just
stored in memory and then later we'll
hook in superbase and then we'll just
return the response. That is it. It is a
super simple function. And then for our
main function we're just going to loop
forever taking the input from the user
and then if they exit we'll let them
exit from the program. Otherwise, we
will call our chat with memories
function with the user input, the latest
user message to get that next response
and do everything with memero that we
covered in this function. And we're just
using the default value of default user
uh for the user ID. That's why we only
have one parameter here. But that is it.
That is our version one. So now let's go
ahead and test this out. So I have my
Python environment already set up and my
environment variable set. So now I'm
just running the command Python
iterations and then version one basic
mem. And so we're in a chat interface
here with GBT40 Mini. I can just say
something really basic like hi. And
we'll get a response. At this point,
nothing will be stored for our memories
because there's just nothing worth
saving at this point. And I'll prove to
you right here that we don't have
conversation history at all because I'll
ask what did I just say? And if we were
storing more than just the latest user
message, then it would be able to tell
us that we said hi. But right here, it
isn't able to recall previous
conversations or statements. And so we
have no conversation history, but I can
still have it store a memory. And so
I'll say something new like, I like all
kinds of cheese except goat cheese,
which is true, by the way. I like
everything besides goat cheese, even
blue cheese. I don't know what it is
about goat cheese. But there we go. We
got a response. And then behind the
scenes, it called that memos add
function to add that memory. And so even
though we don't have conversation
history at all, I can still ask it what
are my food
preferences and we'll get a response. It
knows because it retrieved from the
long-term memory, not the conversation
history, what my preferences are as far
as cheese. And it doesn't matter how
many messages or conversations there are
in between the statement and when it has
to recall that memory. We're still going
to be able to retrieve this because it's
stored in that long-term knowledge base
which right here it's just storing in
memory within the script that I'm
running here. But once we move on to
Superbase, it'll store the embeddings
for the memories in Superbase and we can
see them in our database. And so let's
do that right now. So, I probably could
have included Superbase straight away in
version one, but I wanted to keep that
version as simple as possible. But
luckily, adding Superbase in is not that
difficult cuz watch, I'm going to do
this in just a few lines. Watch this.
Boom. That is it. We just have to change
the configuration for our Mem Zero
client. Specifying now for our vector
store, instead of using the default
in-memory method for storing our
memories, we want to use superbase. And
then for the connection string, we just
have this set up as an environment
variable. And so going
toev.ample, I have instructions as a
comment here for how to set this up.
Also, I'll just show you right here
really quick. If you go into your
Superbase instance, click on connect in
the top middle. Go down to transaction
pooler and then view parameters. These
are all your parameters. You can also
just copy this connection string right
here. It's so easy. The only thing that
you have to fill in is your placeholder
for your database password. So, as long
as you got that, hopefully you remember
that, then you're good to go. And then I
also made it so you can make your model
dynamic based on an environment variable
as well. Those are the only changes. The
rest of this is exactly the same as
version one. And now we have Superbase
set up. So, we can talk to our agent and
watch our memories get stored in
Superbase. And I'll show you that. It is
so cool. Now, back in the terminal, we
are running version two instead of
version one. And going over to my
Superbase instance, the memories table.
This is where Memzero will put all of
our memories is completely empty. And by
the way, to get to this, you need to go
to the VEX schema. It's different than
the public schema, which you're probably
used to as Superbase. So go to VEX and
you'll find this table here, which Memur
will create for you. So you don't even
have to go and execute SQL yourself. It
is very, very convenient. So let's go
back over to the terminal, have a chat
with it, and watch our memories pop up
in Superbase. And so again, I'll just
start off with something kind of random.
I'll say uh I will shoot my foot before
I code with PHP again. All right, which
is kind of true by the way. Not a huge
fan of PHP. I much prefer other things
like JavaScript, Python, or Go. U but
yeah, here we go. So, it created the
vector for our memory. That's why we
have this massive list of numbers here.
Um because at first it searched and it
didn't find any memories and then it
made one and then it gave us a response
at the bottom. It seems like you're
really frustrated with PHP. Yes, well
kind of. I mean, I haven't had to deal
with it in a while, but yeah. Back over
to Superbase. I'll refresh my table. And
then boom, there we go. We now have our
first memory. And looking at the
metadata here, we can see what text was
vectorized. User is frustrated with PHP
and does not want to code with it again.
Yep. And then we have the user ID, which
is just default user. And we'll change
this to be something more realistic once
we add superbase authentication. And
then just the created at time stamp as
well. So that's metadata that we've got.
And now to show you that this is really
working as long-term memory, I'm going
to quit my script and restart it
completely. So even if there was
conversation history with what I'm
setting up here, we still have a fresh
instance of the script. And so I'll ask
it what are my coding
preferences? And we'll see what it comes
up with. So, first it searches the
memories. It finds the one that we have
right here. And this is going to work
great even if you have a ton of
memories. By the way, I just have one to
keep everything simple here. And yeah,
it says based on your memories. You seem
to prefer avoiding PHP for coding. I
mean, yes, to say the least, that is
what I said. So, that is working great.
And now, the next thing that we need, we
want something that really handles user
authentication. Right now, we're just
using a default value for the user ID.
So now I'll show you how to set up
superbase authentication use the user ID
from the signedin user for the memory
and we'll have a whole front end for it.
So for version three to demonstrate
superbase authentication I've created a
very simple streamlit user interface. So
most of the code that we see here is
just boilerplate that claude 3.7 helped
me create. So I'm not going to go over
this from scratch like I did the other
two versions but I'll go over it really
quick in case you're curious. I mean,
it's pretty cool how easy it was to set
this up with Streamlit. Um, so we need
our Superbase URL and key to
authenticate to Superbase for the
Superbase authentication. It's kind of
meta, but I hope that makes sense. So,
we just set those as the bottom two
values in ourv file. And then we are
getting our config for me and creating
our mem client in the exact same way.
And then for all signups and signins
through Superbase, we're storing the
user as a part of the user interface
session state. So that way we can pull
the user ID when we are calling into our
Memzero client. So we're using that for
our user ID instead of just that default
user placeholder value that I was using
earlier. So our chat with memories
function is still effectively the same
besides a couple of differences to make
it work well with the interface. But the
important thing here is the user ID is
now actually going to be dynamic instead
of just being hardcoded. So the way that
we do that is down here in the code for
the user interface, we're fetching the
current user. So once they're signed in,
this user value exists. And within it,
we have the user ID. So we're fetching
the user ID like this. This is coming
from Superbase. So that then when we
call chat with memories, instead of not
having that value there, so it was just
that placeholder default value, we're
passing in a legitimate user ID. So now
armed with this, let's try it out. I'll
show you how this works. I'll use a
couple of different test accounts in the
user interface to show how it remembers
things differently depending on which
email I'm signing in with. So for
version three, because it's a Streamlit
app and not a regular Python script,
we're running it with the command
streamllet run and then the path to
version three. That'll automatically
open up this page in our browser where
we can now log in on the lefth hand
side. So I have a couple of old emails
that I'm using for some test accounts
here. Let me go ahead and log into one
of these. So I'll go ahead and log in.
And then boom, we are now logged in with
this account. And this is using
Superbase for authentication. So there's
nothing that's mocked here at all. We
already have Superbase O set up. It's
very, very easy. And it even shows us
our current user ID. So we can use this
to reference with the memories that are
stored and make sure that it is actually
storing the information for our current
user. And we can clear our memories as
well. And so let's go ahead and tell it
something. I'll say that I think we have
already achieved AGI and people are just
hush hush about it. So I'm giving it an
opinion. Obviously something that it
should store as a memory for me. So
let's watch it rip. Give it some time to
store that memory. And there we go. All
right. So if I go back over to Superbase
now and I refresh, we have that old
record from testing version two. But now
we have this new record. The user
believes we have already achieved AGI
and people are hush- hush about it. And
the user ID instead of being that
placeholder default user like we saw
with version two, we have a real user ID
from Superbase now. And I can copy this
and go back to the interface and search.
Yep, sure enough, that maps exactly to
the user ID that Streamlet says I have.
And so now what I can do is I can log
out and then I can log into another
account and see that our memories will
be stored separately. So I'm going to
use another one of my old emails here
and log in. All right, sweet. And the
conversation is still here, but remember
the agent doesn't keep track of
conversation history. So I I could just
refresh, but I'm just going to keep
going here. I'll say I don't think we
have achieved AGI at all. So I'll send
in this message. And so now it'll store
a memory, a complete opposite memory
compared to the other user. I'm doing
this on purpose that I don't think we've
achieved AGI. And so now I'll go back to
Superbase, refresh the table again, and
now we have a third record. User does
not think we have achieved AGI at all.
And this user ID is different. It maps
to who we are currently logged in as
right now. And so now if I ask the
question, uh, do you think we have
achieved AGI? Maybe that's not the best
way to word it because I want it to tell
me what I think, but we'll see if this
works here. I'm asking if we've achieved
AGI. Based on your memory, you believe
that we have not achieved AGI. But watch
this. I'm going to log out and then I'm
going to log back in to my first
account.
And this is why you'll see this is why
I'm purposefully doing very opposite
memories here because I'll just paste
the exact same question. Do you think
we've achieved AGI? And I'm doing this
on purpose to show that because we are
segregating by user ID, there is
absolutely no chance that the agent will
accidentally reference a memory from a
different user. So we're guaranteed to
get the right response even though this
completely different information. So
based on what you've shared, we you
believe we have already achieved AGI and
that discussions are being withheld from
the public. And also I'm giving both
opinions here because I don't really
know which I truly believe. That's a
whole different discussion. But yeah,
this is working absolutely perfect. For
one account, it says one thing. For
another it says the complete opposite
because it's just referencing the memory
based on the user data that we have, the
user ID in the metadata. So this is
working absolutely perfectly. And as I
already said, a lot of this is just
examples to get you started with Mem
Zero. So certainly a lot that you want
to do to take this further, really build
it into your AI agents to take it to
production. But this does lay a good
foundation to get you started. So go
ahead and take this and run with it. And
Mem Zero does do a lot behind the scenes
for you. So even with just a basic
implementation, this is a pretty
powerful version of long-term memory.
And if you're curious how Memzero works
behind the scenes, what kind of extra
power it gives you, I'll cover that in a
bonus segment coming up here. So check
that out if you're interested. But
that's everything that we've got for the
code today. The core two functionalities
for me zero, which you can integrate
with any agent framework by the way, is
adding memories and then searching for
them. And in this diagram, they show
what it looks like in a very nice way.
So for adding memories, you have your
messages that come in through a
conversation and then you have a large
language model that is prompted
specifically to extract key memories
from the conversation. So this is
different from your main agent. This is
a memory portion of your system. And so
these new memories are added into a
vector database. So you essentially have
this rag setup, this knowledge base for
each individual user conversing with
your agent. And you can take mem even
further as well with a graph knowledge
implementation. It's a more advanced use
case I won't get into in this video. Um,
but you can store entities and relations
as well to make it even more powerful.
But with rag and the vector database,
this is generally enough. And the
important thing here is it's a lot more
than just rag because you're segregating
data by users and also mem under the
hood is doing important things like
conflict resolution. So when you have
new memories coming in, making sure that
you aren't duplicating these memories
when there might be something else
already there that is an existing
similar memory. So that is everything
for adding a memory. And then for
searching memories, we have another nice
diagram. So everything that we're
looking at right here, this is executed
before our primary AI agent because it's
responsible for fetching the most
relevant memories to supply our agent
with that long-term memory capability.
So we have an LLM that intelligently
rewrites the query to extract the most
relevant information from our vector
database. And again, you can use mem to
take things much further with knowledge
graphs as well. And so whatever those
relevant memories are, when it pulls
that from the vector database, that is
fed into our AI agent. And just like
with adding memories, there's a lot more
that Mezero does behind the scenes than
you'd think as well because they
implement advanced rag techniques like
reranking relevant scores, including all
the metadata and timestamps, really
making sure that that long-term memory
is super robust. And there are platforms
out there like chat GBT that actually
integrate something kind of like mem. So
there are platforms that do things
better than Gemini. Um but the level of
customization and control that you have
with Mem Zero. You can just look through
their Python or Node SDKs. You have so
much room here to really make the
long-term memory fit the best to your
use case with the way that you add and
search memories. It is just so powerful.
So I hope that this was a clear and
concise guide for you on how to
implement long-term memory for your AI
agents. And the best part about all of
this is Memzero is really easy to
integrate no matter your use case or the
framework that you are using. And I'm
definitely planning on making more
content on Mem in the future. Things
like advanced use cases, integrating
with different platforms and setting up
the graph memory as well. So if you
appreciated this content and you're
looking forward to more things AI
agents, I would really appreciate a like
and a subscribe. And with that, I will
see you in the next